abriendo la puerta al futuro de ucrania
en la unión europea los líderes del
bloque concedieron al país estatus de
candidato en bruselas decisión que fue
celebrada por el presidente vladimir
selenski
acabamos de recibir la candidatura esta
es nuestra victoria choca o esto
asimismo entre otros
la hemos esperado durante 120 días y
durante 30 años venceremos al enemigo y
descansaremos y probablemente primero
reconstruiremos ucrania y luego
descansaremos
la medida fue aclamada como histórica
por los líderes de la unión europea que
también aceptaron la solicitud de
moldavia mientras a georgia otro estado
ex soviético se le dijo que obtendría el
estatus una vez que cumpliera con más
condiciones típicamente estoy convencida
que la decisión de hoy nos fortalece a
todos
ucrania moldavia georgia y la unión
europea unidos frente a la amenaza
externa en
situ interfax y lo estamos ofreciendo
ucrania moldavia y georgia una
perspectiva europea es una señal muy
fuerte con respecto a rusia y en el
contexto geopolítico que mencionamos
siero en contención política y nos dijo
que hemos tomado la decisión de otorgar
a ucrania y moldavia un estatus de
candidato para unirse a la unión europea
a niño hotel ucrania solicitó la
membresía días después de que rusia
invadiera su territorio albania que
también ha sido candidato oficial
durante ocho años
contra cualquier esperanza irrazonable
en un proceso rápido
macedonia del norte es candidata desde
hace 17 años si no he perdido la cuenta
albania desde los 8
así que bienvenido ucrania es bueno
otorgarle el estatus de candidato pero
espero que el pueblo ucraniano no se
haga muchas ilusiones al respecto los
cuatro países de los balcanes
occidentales están profundamente
frustrados por el estancamiento de sus
intentos de unirse a la unión europea y
tres de ellos amenazaron con boicotear
la reunión como símbolo de protesta la
pertenencia al bloque viene con una
larga lista de condiciones para ucrania
significará llevar a cabo reformas
judiciales y comerciales y erradicar la
corrupción el proceso podría llevar
alrededor de una década